اذا مشاهدينا نستكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه
كما نتابع بهذه الاثناء اصوات اطلاق
النيران الكثيفه والاشتباكات التي ما زالت
دائره في العاصمه الخرطوم بالرغم من دخول
حيز تنفيذ الهدنه نحن دخلنا التوقيت الذي
كان معلن للهدنه بين الطرفين الاشتباكات
ارتفعت حدتها بالساعه الماضيه قبل دخول حي
التنفيذ الهدنه على امل كان ان تهدا مع
دخول يعني حيز تنفيذ الهدنه والتوقيت الذي
كان معلن لها حتى الساعه حتى هذه الدقيقه
لم تتوقف الاشتباكات بانتظار معرفه ما اذا
كانت يعني ستتوقف وفعلا ستدخل هذه الهدنه
حيث تنفذ فلنستمع لصوت الطبيعي واعود
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات